so if it's true that CIA had a hand in
this assassination how is it possible
for them to amass so much power how is
it possible for them to become corrupt
and is it individuals or is it the
entire institution no it's not the
entire institution my daughter-in-law
who's helping to run my campaign was a
CIA uh you know in the clandestine
services
for all her career she was a spy and the
weapons of mass destruction program in
the Middle East and in China
and there's 22 000 people who work for
the CIA probably 20 000 of those are you
know are patriotic Americans and really
good public servants and they're doing
important work for our country
but the institution is corrupt and and
because the higher ranks the institution
and in fact Mike Pompeo said something
like this to me the other day it was the
director of the CIA said when I was
there I did not go to do a good job of
cleaning up that agency and he said the
entire upper bureaucracy
of that agency are people who do not
believe in the institutions of of
democracy
this is what he said to me so I don't
know if that's true but I know that you
know that's significant he's a smart
person and he ran the agency and he was
the Secretary of State
um but it's no mystery how that happened
we know the history the CIA was
originally first of all there was great
reluctance in 1947 that we had it for
the first time we had a secret
spy agency in this country during World
War II called the OSS
that was disbanded after the war because
Congress said
having his Secrets by agency is
incompatible
with a democracy Secrets by agencies are
things that like the KGB the Stasi and
East Germany's vac and Iran and uh Peep
and Chile whatever you know all over the
world they're all have to do with
totalitarian governments they're not
something that you can have that um it's
it's antithetical as a democracy to have
that but
um in 1947 we created Truman signed it
in but it was an initially
and has to be an agency
which means information gathering which
is important it's to get to to gather
and consolidate information
many many different sources from all
over the world and then put those in
reports of the White House or the
president
um can make good decisions based upon
valid information
evidence-based you know decision making
but Alan Ellis who was the you know
essentially the first head of the agency
made a series of
legislative machinations and political
imaginations they gave
additional powers to the agency and
opened up the uh what they called and
the plans division which is the plans
division is the dirty tricks it's the
Black Ops
fixing elections
um murdering what they call Executive
action which means killing
foreign leaders
um and you know making small Wars and uh
and bribing and blackmailing
people's dealing elections that kind of
thing and the reason at that time you
know we were in the middle of the Cold
War
and Truman and then Eisenhower did not
want to go to war they didn't want to
commit troops
and it seemed to them that you know this
was a way of kind of fighting the Cold
War secretly without and doing it at
minimal cost I um uh by uh changing
events sort of invisibly
and so it was seductive to them but
everybody you know Congress when they
first voted it in place Congress both
political parties said
if we create this thing it could turn
into a monster and it could undermine
our you know our values and today it's
it's so powerful and nobody knows what
its budget is plus it has its own
investment fund
inql which has invested you know made I
think 2 000 investments in Silicon
Valley so it has ownership of a lot of
these tech companies that you know and
the a lot of the CEOs those tech
companies
State secrecy agreements with the CIA
which if they even reveal that they have
signed that they can go to jail for 20
years and have their assets removed Etc
the influences the agency has the
capacity to influence events at every
level in our country
are is really uh frightening and then
for most of it's
um for most of its life the CIA was
banned from propagandizing Americans
but we learned that they were doing it
anyway so in 1973 during the church
committee hearings we learned
that the CIA had a program called
operation Mockingbird
where they had at least 400 members
leading members of the United States
press Corps
and the New York Times The Washington
Post ABC CBS NBC Etc
who are secretly working for the agency
and um and steering news coverage uh to
support CIA priorities
and they agreed at that time to disband
operation Mockingbird in 73.
but there's there's indications they
didn't do that and they still the CIA
today is the biggest funder of
Journalism around the world
the biggest funder is through usaid
I'm the USA the United States funds
journalism in almost every country in
the world you know it owns newspapers it
has journalists on thousands and
thousands of journalists on its payroll
they're not supposed to be doing that in
the United States but um you know in
President Obama changed the law to make
it legal now for the CIA to propagandize
Americans and I think you know we can't
look at the Ukraine war and how that was
you know has been how the narrative has
been formed in the in the minds of
Americans
and say that the CIA had nothing to do
with that what is the mechanism I wish
to say influences The Narrative do you
think it's indirectly through the Press
indirectly through the press or directly
by funding the Press directly through
I mean there's certain press organs that
have been linked you know to the agency
that the people who run those organs uh
things like The Daily Beast now rolling
you know editor of note rolling Noah
schlachmann
as deep relationships with the
intelligence Community a salon
daily coasts
um but I wonder why they would do it so
from my perspective it just seems like
the job of a journalist is to have an
Integrity where European cannot be
influenced or bought I agree with you
but I actually think that the entire
field of Journalism has uh
has uh you know really ashamed itself in
recent years because it's become you
know the the principled newspapers in
this country and the television station
the Legacy Media
have abandoned their
um
they're traditional their tradition of
of you know which was when I was a kid
listen my house was filled with the
greatest journalists alive at that time
people like Ben Bradley like Anthony
Lewis Mary mcgrory
Pete Hamill Jerry Jack Newfield uh Jimmy
Breslin
uh uh and many many others and after my
father after my father died they started
the RFK journalism Awards
to recognize integrity and courage you
know journalistic interior courage and
for that generation of Journalism
they they thought they believed that
that the function of a journalists was
to maintain this posture of fierce
skepticism toward any aggregation of
power and including government Authority
now you always the people in Authority
lie and that way they always have to be
questioned and uh and that their job was
to speak truth power and to be Guardians
of the First Amendment right to to uh
free expression
but if you look what happened during the
pandemic
was the inverse of that kind of
Journalism where
the uh the major press organs in this
country
um were instead of speaking truth to
power they were doing the opposite they
were Broadcasting
propaganda they became propaganda organs
for the government agencies and they
were actually censoring um the speech of
anybody who descends of the powerless
oh and in fact it was it was an
organized conspiracy you know and it was
the name of it was The Trusted news
initiative and you know some of the
major press organs in our country signed
on to it and they agreed
not to print stories or facts that um
that departed from government Orthodoxy
so the Washington Post was the signature
of the UPI
the AP and then the um the four Media or
the four social media on groups
Microsoft Twitter
uh Facebook and Google all signed on to
the trusted news initiative it was
started by the BBC organized by them
and the purpose of it
was to make sure nobody could print
anything about government that departed
from government Orthodox is the way it
worked is the UPI the AP and the which
are the news services that provide most
of the new you know news around the
country
and the Washington Post would decide
what news was permissible to print
and a lot of it was about covet but also
Hunter finds laptops where you it was
the impermissible to suggest that those
were real or that you know they had
stuff on there that was compromising
and um
and we you know and by the way
I this what I'm telling you is all well
documented and I'm litigating on it
right now so I'm part of a lawsuit
against the dni
and so I know a lot about what happened
and I have all this documented and
people can go to our website there's a
letter
on my sub stack now to um to Michael's
share of the Washington Post that
outlines all this and gives all my
sources
um because Michael Sheriff accused me of
being a conspiracy theorist when he was
actually part of a conspiracy a true
conspiracy
to suppress anybody
who is departing from government
orthodoxies by either censoring them
completely or labeling them conspiracy
theorists
I I mean you can understand the
intention
and the action the difference between as
we talked about you can understand the
intention of such a thing being good at
a time of a catastrophe the time of a
pandemic uh there's a lot of risk to
saying
untrue things but that's a slippery
slope that leads into yeah a place where
the journalistic Integrity that we
talked about is completely sacrificed
and then you can deviate from truth if
you read their internal memorandum
including the statements of the the
leader of the trusted news and it's I
think her name is Jessica Jennifer Cecil
um and I you know you can go on our
website and see her say amen and she
said she says
the purpose of this is that we're now I
say she says when people look at us they
think we're competitors but we're not
the real competitors are coming from all
these alternative news sources now all
over the network uh and they're
hurting public trust in us and they're
hurting our economic model and we have
to they have to be choked off and
crushed and uh and the way that we're
going to do that is to
make an agreement with the social media
sites that if we say if we label their
information misinformation the social
media sites will um will de-platform it
or they will throttle it or they will uh
Shadow ban it
which destroys the economic model of
those alternative competitive sources of
information so that that's true but and
but the point you make is an important
point
um that the journalists themselves
who probably didn't know about the TNI
agreement certainly I'm sure they didn't
um they believe that they're doing the
right thing by suppressing information
that May challenge you know government
proclamations on covet
but I mean there's a danger to that and
the danger is that
you know once you appoint yourself an
Arbiter of what's true and what's not
true
uh then there's really no end to the
power that you have now assumed for
yourself because
and now your your job is no longer to
inform the public your job now is to
manipulate the public
and if you end up manipulating the
public in collusion with powerful
entities then you become the instrument
of authoritarian rule rather than the
you know the the opponent of it and it
becomes the inverse of Journalism and a
democracy